the premise of the show is based over
360 years in the future science has
provided humans with innovations that
were once only a dream flying cars ai
generated services and several medical
breakthroughs are some of the most
prominent new discoveries however on the
top of the list is an invention called
the stack it is a chip embedded into the
vertebrae at the back of the neck this
device records a person's memories and
consciousness some people also call it
the soul of modern humans as it contains
data about everything that has ever
happened in a person's life using a
stack the rich have found a way to live
like immortals when their bodies die all
they have to do is transfer the stack to
a new body which they call the sleeve
that way they can change sleeves again
and again and live forever as long as
the stack remains intact the poor are
also allowed to have such services but
it is not very convenient for them
firstly buying a new sleeve costs a lot
of money sometimes the less fortunate
have to use any sleeve they can get
which means a man's stack can be stuck
in a woman's body a child's and an adult
and so on this is not a problem for the
wealthy because they clone their
original bodies to make customized
sleeves so even if they die they are
automatically brought back to life in a
new clone in the new digitalized world
the prison system has also changed when
someone is convicted of a crime their
stack is taken out of their bodies and
kept confined that way they do not get
to live for a said period of time until
they complete their sentence after they
serve their time they are given random
sleeves to return to the normal world
one morning in the prison's medical
center the inmates are being re-sleeved
and released one guy in particular
struggles to return to life and hits the
doctor in frustration the body belongs
to a stranger but the person wearing the
body is a man named takeshi kovacs he
has been in prison for two and a half
centuries which is why he is confused
the doctors calm him down before
reporting that he has served his
sentence and is about to be released
takeshi looks at himself in a mirror and
sees a stranger staring back he inquires
whose body he is in but even the doctors
do not know 250 years ago takeshi used
to be a prominent member of a rebel
group called the envoys they were
painted as maniacs by historians because
they wanted to destroy all stacks in the
world and bring back mortality a
flashback shows us how takeshi was
arrested years ago he was with a partner
in a hotel room when the police known as
the protectorate barged inside they had
already killed all the envoys in their
hideout hence takeshi was the last envoy
to be arrested after catching up with
the world takeshi goes outside and meets
a police lieutenant named kristen she
has been sent by someone powerful to
give him a ride takeshi has a lot of
questions that she claims will be
answered when he meets someone named
bancroft bancroft is the most powerful
man in the modern world he is the
wealthiest and has connections in about
every part of the world initially
takeshi was never supposed to be brought
back to society but for some reason
bancroft wanted him out he and kristen
are received by bancroft's wife miriam
she asks kristen to go away and brings
takeshi inside the house he senses that
she is trying to seduce him which is
strange considering her husband is the
wealthiest man on earth not that strange
though rich people have the weirdest
fetishes in all the land takeshi finally
meets bancroft and inquires why he was
brought back to life bancroft gets to
the point and reveals that he was killed
a month ago his data was backed up so he
came back to life but he lost the memory
of the last 48 hours prior to his death
the police have done their investigation
and concluded that bancroft committed
the unthinkable however he believes
their investigation is [ __ ] he is a
hundred percent sure he would never do
something to harm himself and even if he
did he wouldn't fail hence the only
possible explanation for the death is
that he was murdered he needed the most
intelligent mind in the world to solve
the case for him which is why takeshi
has been revived before being mass
murdered envoys were a powerful group
they learned the great power of
intuition and problem solving which
still remains a secret to the rest of
the world currently only takeshi has
those skills so bancroft wants him to
find his murderer in turn for his
freedom takeshi gives it a thought and
then refuses to help him the main aim of
envoys was to go against people like
bencroft hence he would rather be stuck
in a stack forever than help him still
bancroft gives him a day to think it
over following the conversation takeshi
goes to the slums part of town and buys
a bunch of illegal pills he eventually
ends up in the red light zone surrounded
by virtual advertisements of brothels
since he is high the advertisement looks
real and he almost loses his mind
fortunately kristen comes to his aid and
gives him an ad blocker takeshi
questions her being too interested in
him but kristen argues it's because he
is a national terrorist the two then go
to a strip club to discuss bancroft's
death kristin was the lead cop in the
investigation which is why she is
positive that it was a case of self-harm
takeshi doesn't believe her but he has
no interest in taking the case so he
dismisses the conversation altogether he
leaves first and goes to an ai hotel
down the road the owner of the place is
an ai named poe he hasn't had a customer
in over 50 years and is excited to
finally receive one before takeshi can
check in he is approached by a hitman
named dimi and his henchmen dimi has
been sent by someone to fetch takeshi
but when takeshi insults him he derails
from the primary plan and gets
aggressive poe cleverly tells takeshi
that once he pays he will be entitled to
the hotel's security services amidst the
fight the envoy manages to pay and the
opponents are killed by the hotel's
automated security system dimi also dies
before revealing who sent him a while
later kristen and her partner arrive to
investigate the shootings dimi's
presence in the gang tells them that the
person who sent the thugs is someone
high profile but this also means it will
be very difficult to track them when
everything calms down takeshi goes into
the elevator and gets high once again
then he imagines talking to the leader
of the envoys quell she was the one true
love of his life before she was killed
in the mass murder of envoys in the
following scene we see a fisherman
finding a dead body in the sea it is of
a prostitute named mary lou back in the
hotel takeshi is visited by bancroft's
lawyer she brings him to psychosack the
place where the clones of wealthy people
are kept and dealt with they are here to
watch the surveillance video of the day
when the murder took place it turns out
bancroft was in osaka for half of the
day before he returned to the city but
the only video taken after his return is
one where miriam kisses him briefly as
he inspects the video bancroft arrives
and takeshi agrees to help him in turn
for his freedom he plans to fulfill the
purpose of the envoys after he gains
complete freedom at the police station
kristin is asked to talk to a bereaved
mother about her daughter's dead body
she is the mother of the prostitute mary
lou whose body was found in the sea that
morning kristen calms the mother down
but is actually interested in the case
back in the hotel po shows to catchy all
the videos of death threats made upon
bancroft that year there are more than 4
000 videos with different people on them
and anyone could be the killer but with
takeshi's deduction skills he drops the
options down to 20 videos out of them
only one man hasn't shown his face poe
traces the man's address and finds out
he is named elliot in the following
scene takeshi goes to meet elliot who
mistakes him for an enemy he holds
takeshi at gunpoint but it is easy for
him to overpower the man after all he's
ripped like a goddamn elephant after
tying him to a chair takeshi sits on his
station and goes to the virtual place
there he meets eliot's daughter lizzy
who is in a dark alleyway alone and
scared elliot explains that his wife was
arrested for hacking and his daughter
lizzie disappeared right after one day
before her disappearance she said that
she was in a relationship with bancroft
this makes elliott believe bancroft is
the cause of her disappearance which is
why he sent the death threat elliot
managed to find lizzy's stack but her
body is dead and he cannot afford a new
sleeve moreover she has suffered great
mental trauma and is shut down from life
still stuck in the alleyway she was
thrown at after finding out everything
about elliot takeshi comes to the
conclusion that he is not the killer
following the encounter he goes to the
city's envoy museum he meets a little
girl who is extra chatty with him the
girl seems to know something about him
but takeshi fails to recognize it then
he takes a trip to the red light zone
again because he has discovered that
lizzie used to be a prostitute to
investigate takeshi buys a girl
pretending to be lizzy's mother in a
man's sleeve the girl doesn't doubt him
and reveals that bancroft was a regular
customer he likes to choke girls until
they die which he has done to many
prostitutes however all of them think of
him as a good man because he buys them
an upgraded sleeve after they die
that's [ __ ] up the prostitute promises
to talk around and find out more about
what happened to lizzie when takeshi
steps out of the brothel he finds elliot
pointing his gun at him he wants to know
why takeshi is interested in lizzie but
before getting an answer they are
attacked by robbers takeshi kills all of
them and ends up in jail by the end of
the night he is eventually bailed out by
bancroft's lawyer upon reaching the
hotel takeshi finds miriam waiting for
him she seduces him and the two end up
making love with one another what they
do not know is that someone is recording
them through a secret camera joke's on
them if they think takeshi gives a damn
the following morning takeshi dreams of
himself and his sister reading stories
when they were young both of them had a
traumatic childhood which he doesn't
like to talk about later poe shows him
an invitation from bancroft to an
exclusive party the attendees of the
party include everyone who might want
bancroft dead so takeshi has to be there
to investigate at the same time kristin
is also invited as the head of security
for the night she knows that bancroft
doesn't like her which makes the
invitation suspicious she is skeptical
about going until she discovers that
every suspect from mary lou's death case
will be at the party this will give her
an opportunity to investigate which she
doesn't want to miss somewhere else
takeshi again goes to elliot and asks
him to be his backup for the party in
turn he promises to provide lizzie with
a virtual treatment for her mental
health elliott doesn't dwell before
accepting the offer for his daughter
then they go to the hotel and meet poe
he will be lizzy's companion for the
time she will be treated in the virtual
world he creates a nice space for her
and brings her away from the dirty
alleyway she was in the price is
expensive but takeshi has a tab given to
him by the wealthiest man on the planet
for the first time in years lizzie
speaks and talks to poe elliott is
relieved that she is finally making
progress in the next scene takeshi
arrives at the party and is received by
miriam the highlight of the party is
sleeve combat about to take place later
a married couple will fight each other
to the death and the one who wins will
win an upgraded sleeve for their partner
it is a win-win situation although they
have to suffer until they die at the
hands of each other takeshi and kristen
share a brief conversation before they
get to looking for murders for the
respective cases they are working on
kristin notices a man looking at her
from the side of the room he seems
suspicious so she tells her colleague to
check his profile however the camera
embedded in her eye doesn't seem to
record the guy elliott on the other hand
is disguised as a waiter he goes to the
surveillance room to steal cctv footage
from the day his daughter disappeared in
the middle of the party takeshi notices
miriam entering a hidden room behind the
bookshelves he follows her and catches
her having sex with the head of security
but it turns out the woman isn't miriam
but one of her daughters in her mother's
sleeve what did i say about rich people
kings takeshi interrogates her about her
father's death because she might have
dressed up as her mother and killed him
that night the woman however argues that
she will be left penniless as per
bancroft's will if he dies hence all 21
of his children should be crossed out
from the list of suspects a while later
the sleeve combat takes place in the
middle of it bancroft orders the male
fighter to fight and defeat takeshi for
a more advanced upgrade takeshi is
forced into the battlefield and he has
to fight even though he doesn't want to
kill the couple in the end takeshi kills
the male opponent at his wife's request
so they get a better upgrade and come
back to life after the party takeshi
goes to the brothel yet again to meet
the girl from yesterday but she betrays
him by drugging him when he opens his
eyes he is being pushed into a
hospital-like facility it turns out to
be a virtual torture room where people
are tortured and killed in the virtual
world again and again until they confess
their crimes he has been kidnapped by
dimi's younger twin brother whose name
is also dimi the guy is a sadistic
maniac who wants revenge for his
brother's death he starts the
interrogation by beating takeshi off
with a chain and strangling him then he
is chained to a metal table and his
shoulder is broken back in the hotel
elliot goes through the surveillance
footage but finds nothing about lizzie
all he knows is that she was tortured to
the point of insanity he wants to meet
her but poe doesn't allow him to since
it might mess with her treatment back in
the torture chamber dimi addresses
takeshi as riker and asks him who he is
working for eventually takeshi registers
that riker is the name of the sleeve he
is wearing but since he knows nothing
about the guy it makes dimi even angrier
while getting beaten to death takeshi
remembers quell's training in the envoy
camp the envoys were taught what to do
at times like this the main trick is to
use hallucination displacement and
retreat as moves in a game first by
showing the perpetrator that you are
strong then by breaking the shell and
lastly by striking back however it is
much easier said than done because
takeshi hardly gets a chance to think
amidst the torture meanwhile at the
police station kristen is inspecting the
video from bancroft's party she clearly
remembers seeing this strange man
staring at her but none of the cameras
have caught him he has somehow found a
way to trick all the surveillance
cameras which could be a huge trouble
later on kristin calls the guy a ghost
walker and continues looking more into
this disappearing technique somewhere
else dimi plucks all of takeshi's
fingernails then shoots him in the head
after suffering a horrible death he
comes back to life only to be tortured
again similarly takeshi is burned his
limbs are torn and his eyes are gouged
out but dimi doesn't get the answer he
is looking for in takeshi's head he
remembers the time he suffered the same
pain and training quel's words act as
motivation for him as he continuously
plays her in his mind when all the usual
techniques do not work dimi buys the
special torture package and brings out a
box of carnivore reptiles then he makes
a hole in takeshi's stomach and lets the
reptile into his body it is the worst
pain the envoy has ever felt one that no
amount of training could prepare him for
he starts talking to himself repeating
the words hallucination displacement and
retreat suddenly he reaches a higher
level of consciousness and is able to
free his hands to take control he rips
his own heart out and ends up being
disconnected from the vr world the plan
works and he comes back to reality but
he is still in the torture facility
surrounded by workers who are being paid
to break him to get out of the situation
he pretends to be a protectorate officer
who has been transferred to riker's body
the workers panic and free him from the
wires asking for forgiveness dimi tries
to stop them but they care about their
jobs more than their clients however
they regret their decision as soon as
takeshi is let out because he shoots and
kills everyone in the room then he walks
out with dimi's head in his hands and
meets elliot outside a while later
kristen finds out what happened and
barges into takeshi's room to ask him
what is going on takeshi in turn asks
her what her relationship with riker is
at first she denies knowing anyone named
riker but then it turns out he was her
boyfriend he was a framed cop whose
stack was taken out as punishment in
turn his body was given to takeshi which
is why she has been following him
to see what happens next watch the
second part in series recapped
you